[Music]
does god exist
whether you believe in god don't believe
in god or
aren't quite sure this question has been
posed by just about
every philosopher and every culture in
history
what made the universe what made
us is there someone
or something answering my prayers
throughout history there have been many
efforts to prove god's existence
not scientifically because as of yet
there is no scientific evidence for god
but
philosophically in this video i'd like
to go over the four
most important philosophical arguments
for the existence of god
the cosmological argument the
teleological argument
the ontological argument and the moral
argument and go over
some of their counter-arguments
the first and perhaps most popular is
the cosmological argument as the name
implies
the cosmological argument attempts to
prove god's existence
by looking to the existence of the
universe
or cosmos the argument originated in
ancient greece
with both plato and aristotle writing
versions of it
other philosophers like thomas aquinas
and dun scotus
two medieval catholic priests and
theologians
from italy and scotland respectively
also advocated for versions of it it's
important to note
these names are umbrella terms that
describe
a type of argument for the existence of
god there is no one
cosmological argument or one
teleological argument
but many different arguments espoused by
different people
that when simplified down are
essentially arguing the same thing
but i digress cosmological arguments are
often called
first cause arguments because they
describe a
first cause for the universe they are
arguments that suppose
since the universe exists there must
have been
a cause for its existence here's a
simple version one
everything that has a beginning as a
cause
two the universe had a beginning
three therefore the universe had a cause
and that cause is god this version has
some obvious holes
for one we don't know the universe had a
beginning
we think it probably did but it's not
inconceivable
that the universe is an eternal thing
also
just because it had a cause doesn't mean
the cause
was god it could have been a natural
phenomenon
here's a better though admittedly more
complicated version of the argument
one some contingent beings exist
two contingent beings require a cause
three there must exist a
necessary being as the ultimate cause
for therefore there exists
a necessary being i.e god
so there are a few terms we must explain
a contingent being is simply a thing
that's existence
is dependent on something else for
example you
your existence is contingent on your
parents meeting
if they never met you would not exist
okay so unnecessary being is something
that is not contingent on anything else
what this argument is saying is
essentially the same as the first
but in more let's say tight language it
still isn't airtight
again one could argue that just because
there is a necessary being that must
exist
doesn't mean god exists essentially the
cosmological argument postulates
that for the universe to exist at all
there must be a reason
this makes the argument very popular
because it plays on a natural human
instinct to find a reason for everything
the teleological argument is similar to
the cosmological argument
in that it argues for god's existence
based on the state of the universe
but unlike the cosmological argument it
focuses on the characteristics of the
universe
particularly its design rather than its
mere existence
because of this it's often called the
argument from
design it like the argument just
discussed
goes back to ancient greece and the
greatest propagators of it were the
stoic
philosophers other proponents for the
argument were william turner the
botanist
and william paley the 19th century
english philosopher
the argument posits that the universe is
so complicated and well
ordered that it must have been designed
here it is laid out 1. there exists
in nature a beneficial order to things
two beneficial order is best explained
by intelligent design
three therefore there was an intelligent
designer
i.e god a popular analogy for this
argument
is the watchmaker analogy created by
william paley
say you're walking down a path in the
forest and you happen across
a rock your assumption about the rock's
origins would be
that it came about through natural
causes the rock is simple
uniform and serves no obvious purpose
but say you walk a little further down
the path
and you see a watch on the ground your
assumption would not be the same as with
the raw
the watch was clearly made by someone
it is complex with many intricate parts
and all of those parts are working
together for a purpose
to tell time so a proponent for the
teleological argument
would say that as we look to the
universe
it is much more like the watch than the
rock
like the cosmological argument this
argument is not without its dissenters
first off the claim that the complex
nature of the universe could
only be made by design is not a clear
fact
as science has progressed we see that
many complex phenomena
happen through natural processes a good
example of this
is of course evolution that shows that
complex
things like animals can come to be
through the process of natural selection
in fact when darwin's theories first hit
the market
it was seen by many philosophers to put
the teleological argument to rest
there are modern philosophers who
disagree with his perspective
and argue that the theory could still
work while accepting the truth of
evolution
the teleological argument points to the
probability of god's existence
without trying to give a solid proof of
god outright
still the argument has stood the test of
time and remains popular
likely due to humankind's awe at the
complexity and majesty of our universe
the ontological argument is one of my
favorites
not because it's necessarily convincing
but more so
because of its complexity and outright
strangeness
it's an argument that many people can't
quite get their heads around at first
so hopefully i can explain it well
enough here
the ontological argument unlike the
cosmological or
teleological doesn't argue based on the
existence of the universe
or even anything in the universe but
instead
argues that god exists based solely on
the definition of god
and god's own characteristics it was
first put into words by saint anselm
the famed medieval theologian and bishop
there are
other ontological arguments but we use
his as our example
since it is the best known it goes
something like this
one god is the greatest being of which
it is possible to conceive
two god exists in the minds of humans
three a being that exists only in the
mind
and not in reality is lesser than a
being that exists both in the mind
and in reality four if god
only exists in the mind then god is not
the greatest possible thing that can be
conceived
five therefore god must by definition
exist both in the mind and in reality
so basically it argues that god by
definition
must exist as interesting as this
argument is
it has some major flaws one of these
flaws
was even pointed out by a contemporary
of saint anselm
the monk ganilo after reading the
argument ganilo
came up with a refutation he pointed out
that if you replace
god with say an island the argument
falls apart
say you imagine an island the greatest
island you can
think of it is big and beautiful
the trees all bear delicious fruit there
are no dangerous
animals that will hurt or kill you it is
perfect
of course this island doesn't exist what
ganilo
was pointing out is that existence is
not really a characteristic
that can be tied to greatness when
anselm heard of ganilo's refutation
he stated the argument only works for
necessary beings
not contingent ones the island is a
contingent thing
it can only exist if certain conditions
are met
but god is necessary and isn't
contingent on anything
this seems to many like a cop-out
saying that the argument works because
god is a unique case
still the argument has been very
influential
and it did something that the previous
two did not it gave
god specific characteristics
the last argument we will look at is the
moral argument
like the cosmological and teleological
argument it first appeared in ancient
greece
and has been propagated by the likes of
emmanuel kant
the famed philosopher and c.s lewis
the author of the chronicles of narnia
the argument
per its name argues that god is the
progenitor
of morality and so must exist
failing morals be arbitrary here it is
laid out
one unless there is a god there can be
no objective binding moral obligations
2 there are objective binding
moral obligations 3
therefore god must exist this argument
has
perhaps the most obvious of
counter-arguments
namely that there are no objective moral
obligations
this can be established via cultural
relativism
in which one might believe that morals
are a cultural artifact
and they change from society to society
or
individual relativism where one believes
that people
make up morals for themselves in reality
neither of these counter arguments are
as good as they seem on first viewing
first individual relativism is pretty
wrong on the face of it
as we can see that there is general
consensus on many moral issues
and second most people don't agree with
cultural relativism
it's a hotly debated subject also
cultural relativism doesn't disprove
objective morality
there's nothing to say that all cultures
are morally correct
one culture's morals could simply be
objectively wrong
a much more popular counter to the moral
argument
is that objective morality doesn't
necessarily have to come from
god it could be inherent within humans
due to some natural occurrence
like evolution the moral argument backs
up into the question of ethics
which by itself is an entire branch of
philosophy
one that has been discussed and argued
about for literally thousands of years
because of this it is in my opinion one
of the weaker
arguments we've looked at still the
moral argument does a good job of
employing the moral consciousness
that is near universal within human
beings
hopefully that has given you a lot to
think about by the way
this video is not meant as an
endorsement of any of these arguments
nor
as a refutation of them it is also not
an endorsement of any belief in god nor
non-belief in god please be kind in the
comments
and thanks for watching
hello i really appreciate you checking
out my video
if you want to see more like this please
subscribe like the video if you liked it
leave a comment letting me know what you
think and check out some of my other
videos if you want to learn more
bye
you